We want to take the square root of both sides of the equation. We want to make
sure that at least one of those sides has a plus or minus next to it. Since the
left side doesn't, the right side needs it. So that rules out all of our answers
that don't have plus or minus symbols in front of them. This first answer is
definitely correct because it has a square root sign over the entire expression,
those on the right hand side originally. However, when we have a square root
over a fraction. This is the same as taking the square root of the numerator
over the square root of the denominator. So this choice is correct as well. If
we simplify that denominator, square root of 4a squared, that just gives us 2a,
so the last choice is also correct. There's so many different ways of writing
this, however I think that this last one is probably the most simple, since it
has the fewest radicals involved.